and uh jason
the reporter there joins me now and uh
jason well i've got to say it's one of
the most powerful pieces
of reporting uh in this pandemic just
give us a sense of the intensity you
found in there what struck you about
being in there
i think the first thing you notice is
people's faces the patients
obviously they're the only people's
faces you can see because everyone else
is masked up
and it's one of the things that we don't
really show you um
because we can't get consent and it's
very distressing to see
people there sometimes their eyes are
open but they can't really they're not
really seeing
if if you know what i mean sometimes
their eyes are closed and they're just
covered in tubes in their mouths
sometimes there's a tracheotomy
in the neck to support their breathing
and they all
look like they're gasping for breath
because
if it weren't for the machines they
wouldn't be alive
it's different in different areas so
there might be an icu which is very well
set up
and everything's spaced out and then in
other areas where they've had to adapt
toward
uh there might be it might be a bit more
cramped and my cameraman
andy porch described it as a as like a
field hospital
not he's been in one uh so he he should
know
but not because of the lack not because
of the lack of technology because that's
definitely there but just the atmosphere
and the feel
of people mucking in some of the rooms
are quite hot
feels very hot in the ppe and one of the
things that really struck me
going there was when i've been to
hospitals before it's often been with a
politician
on a campaign trail or something like
that and everything is very stage
managed
and you're told where to point the
camera and who to speak to they just
don't have time for any of that
it's it's it's everyone's mucking in uh
you you saw from the report people from
all over the hospital coming in to bring
in their specialties
uh there's no such thing as a comfort
zone for anybody
because even if they're in that
speciality they're in very different kit
from what they're used to
um and the other thing of course is that
there are people there who are not in
their specialties and you have
consultants
acting as nurses and you know we heard
from
matt hancock that there are 37 000
people
now in the uk hospitals there are
obviously a lot of people
uh there's a lot more lot more than they
used to um the more than ever in this
pandemic on on ventilators and we have
enough ventilators but you've got to
think of the amount of time it takes and
the amount of care
for people to keep those ventilators
functioning and the people on them
you know their eyes uh they need uh
moisturizing
um they they need the tubes clear
clearing they need the machines
monitoring so that all of that is going
on and that requires
people and they are tremendously
dedicated and
jason it's pretty rare i think that we
would run an interview
of someone who subsequently passed away
but uh
tony's widow linda you say wanted this
show
yeah thoughts again with uh tony and
his family and his widow linda he
clearly
thought about her an awful lot in in
those last moments and
um it was just by chance that i happened
to
walk into his world on his on his last
day
a full day alive and
we did the interview and he was actually
on his wa on the phone his wife
afterwards
and so we got his consent and then um he
he spoke to his wife about it
and i just called as i was editing it um
he'd given me his wife's number and i
called her up just to make sure that she
was okay with it it was only then
whilst i was editing the piece that uh
she told me that he had passed away
so you know i um i made sure that she
was okay with us using the interview and
she said if he wanted to do it
then then then i want you know i want it
to go out
um and i spoke to her today she hasn't
watched it
um she thought it would be too traumatic
but members of her family have
and she's very pleased that he's done it
she said he always wanted his 15 minutes
of fame
and she was pleased that he put that
message out there
about people staying safe and i think
she's very happy that he his 15 minutes
of fame
were well used yeah and jason i mean
you'll be doing some more reporting from
this hospital and that
i've seen the staff pretty keen to get
out their
uh message as well
yeah i mean that comes across doesn't it
each and every one of them are just
hoping
that we're living in two different
worlds really aren't we there's the
world outside of these hospitals where
everyone's getting extremely frustrated
and we all are
at the restrictions uh and the social
distancing and not being able to see
loved ones
and then there's a complete and those
people live in that world as well
and they don't get much time in it but
they do live in it and and they
understand
but um when you step into their world
and you see what they're going through
and we'll continue to do that because i
think it's important
now that journalists are you know
embedded in a way as we we just
sometimes are with the military when
we're
in a camp a military campaign i think we
have to be embedded with
uh these um these medics
you know to see what they're going
through and to give the public a window
into their worlds okay jason
thank you very much for being with us
thank you